when you go to a theme park or some
adrenaline-junkie tourist attraction you
expect it to be safe
thrilling sure but safe but how can the
companies that create those rides test a
new one so you've got a new invention
like say a zipline that goes around
corners there are a few rides sort of
liked in the world
but they all use different technologies
and work in different ways there are
standards for things that are
mass-produced how do you test something
that's one-of-a-kind
you really swing outwards on that don't
you
we as a company like to invent and break
and test stuff so we've gone through the
process of testing other people's stuff
to making our own traditionally zip
lines are cheap amusement ride they go
from point A to point B and you need to
have clear line-of-sight and they're
different from a rollercoaster which is
able to go around corners but has an
awful lot of expense in building the
infrastructure to hold the rails up the
difference is our product transitions
from a wire rope cable into a corner
which Israel based that allows you to go
much further zipline can travel
kilometers and a corner can provide a
lot of entertainment we have a patient
of Technology so we've got sole use of
it previously braking systems where
friction based a new system has eddy
current brakes this is a property of
materials that occurs when you move a
magnet through a conductor I have in my
hand an aluminium channel that X is the
conductor if I drop a steel mast down
this aluminum conductor as you would
expect will fall if I now drop a magnet
down this aluminium conductor eddy
current braking will slow it down and it
will fall at a very slow rate we've
captured that and incorporated it into a
80-count break that allows you to have
no contacting parts so there are nowhere
surfaces so there's no brake dust that's
created the brake is configured such
that regardless of the rider weight and
wind conditions and gradient of the
corner you will always fall at a peak
velocity which we have governed no
electronics in there whatsoever it's
solely works on Springs centrifugal
force and 80-count braking regulations
on rides and attractions differ
massively depending on where you are in
some states in the US for example the
job of checking that a ride is safe is
left to the insurance companies who have
to pay out if there was an accident the
only time the government gets involved
something has gone so wrong if a company
has been so negligent that there might
be criminal charges other countries like
New Zealand are a bit more strict there
is a difference between foreseeable
misuse and unforeseeable misuse if
someone gets their phone out on a ride
to take a picture and it falls out of
their hands and
someone's head open underneath well you
should have seen that coming when you
built the right someone was probably
gonna do that you should have put a net
down but if someone deliberately breaks
the restraint so they can stand up on
your roller coaster and that's their own
fault the definitions are deliberately
vague in law though because it's easier
to say that you should do everything
reasonable rather than change the law
every time someone invents something new
most countries have their own national
standards and they are acceptable ways
of doing things they lay out how you
should engineer things how you should
test them it's important to comply with
standards it's also important to show
that you've complied with standards so
that people can trace what you've done
and why through the design process
generally when doing something new
though there isn't a standard that you
can use to encompass the entire product
so what we do is we actually go out and
we look at all the standards and we pick
bits from each of the standards that we
think are most applicable you design a
ride for example a zipline ride you work
out how fast the person is going to go
and how much force they're going to
apply to each of the component if you
have a safety factor of five you
multiplied the maximum that the system
will see by five and you need to design
a test to that factor what we need to do
though is we try and work out what will
go wrong should any part of the system
fail and part of that failure modes and
effects analysis is to work out how
people could do stupid things which they
will you look at the history you look at
what people have done on zip lines in
the past the main thing is to stay
involved right through to seeing the
thing being used spot potential missile
uses and mitigate for them oh here we go
oh man that doesn't look like much from
the outside but when you swing around
that corner it makes a heck of a
difference thank you very much to all
the team at Home Solutions you can pull
down the description for more about them
and their work the first one of these
rides is going in at Pigeon Forge
Tennessee sometime this year thank you
folks